il n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu de
différence si vous voulez entre les
personnes de 75 ans et les personnes
beaucoup plus jeune donc en temps ci des
recueils a malgré tout eu égard au taux
d'anticorps que nous avons avec ses vins
ses vaccins puisque 1 à 2 y'en a deux
aujourd'hui qui ont été approuvés non
non ce que des personnes vont arrêter
pour ans était protégé alors maintenant
la question qui se pose il ya deux
questions qui se posent sur ses vaccins
aujourd'hui la première question c'est
la durée de protection
et c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on n'a pas cette durée de protection on
va le savoir on pense qu'on aura minimum
6 mois
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que on
regarde les patients qui ont été
affectés lors de la première vague si
vous voulez et on regarde leur taux
d'anticorps au regard de la diminution
du taux d'anticorps
donc ça on va le savoir effectivement si
ça dépasse six mois reste mais
logiquement le taux d'anticorps et
d'autant plus d'autant plus longue durée
que là que là que l'infection était il
va pas obligatoirement s'est aperçu
qu'il y avait des gens qui avaient
beaucoup d des symptômes extrêmement
fort et qui avait pas obligatoire
beaucoup d'anti corps et des personnes
qui étaient presque asymptomatiques ou
poterie symptomatique et qui avaient des
anticorps et le deuxième la ddt le
deuxième problème et après je
m'arrêterai madame billie jean
le deuxième problème c est ce que ce
vaccin empêche les formes graves ou mac
et ios qu'il empêche également la
transmission c'est ce qu'on attend la
transmission c'est à dire le portage du
virus alors les essais qui ont été faits
ils ont été faits avec un objectif qui
était un objectif sur les cas graves en
mai chez effectivement l'orage sitôt
cliniques et les formes qui peuvent
entraîner effectivement un décès par
contre on n'a pas assez de recul
aujourd'hui pour voir si ce vaccin on
empêche la transmission dinac tma et
c'est très important
sauf que eu égard au taux d'anticorps
que nous avons avec ces vaccins
on peut considérer que ça va nettement
diminué le portage mais en attend
effectivement avec le temps de savoir si
effectivement ils empêchent la
transmission et c'est pour ça parce que
je m'excuse mais en plus aucun regret
ensuite je n'entende la réponse à la
deuxième place je pense que ça
déterminer la stratégie du gouvernement
et moi je suis pas responsable
c'était l'objet de deux hommes les
essais étaient très concluants sur les
formes graves et qu'on n'avait pas
vraiment de résultats sur la
transmission parce qu'elle aurait pu
dire si c'est la transmission c'est les
jeunes qui transmettent
on va commencer à vacciner à vacciner
les jeunes comme on n'a pas à ces
éléments
le choix qui a été fait sur lequel on
était sûr c'était empêcher des cas
graves effectivement on aura ces
éléments il devient important
effectivement 2
importance hannachi sur la deuxième
question est ce que c'était la bonne
chose de choisir les personnes les plus
vulnérables ou de compter sur les gens
qui voulaient le faire quel que soit
leur état
pour le coup pour rebondir ce qui vient
des 10 la stratégie se vérifie
aujourd'hui la positivité des stratégies
se vérifie par le fait qu'on protège des
complications et non pas de la contagion
partant de ce principe
effectivement il va le vacciner les
personnes les plus à risque pour deux
raisons pour elle évidemment parce que
oui mais les bras que des personnes
arrivent dans les personnes âgées dans
les ehpad et des personnes à risque par
93% alors pour deux raisons d'abord 93 %
de la mortalité cédé plus de 65 ans donc
c'est quand même pas rien mais ça veut
dire enfin vous habitez une question de
vie aussi parce que 84 % de la mortalité
c'est chez les vieux quand vous êtes
dans un mail mais quand vous êtes vous
êtes dans un ehpad
souvent vous êtes plus dépendants
d'ailleurs c'est le d2 est une atteinte
à peine appelé à mourir récemment que
quelqu'un qu'à 20 ans aussi
j'ai dit voilà c'est un choix éthique
non mais on peut en discuter mais c'est
un choix éthique
un disque que je ne ferai pas un c'est
très discutable non là c'est un choix
était que je ferais pas mais bon tu
table quand c'est parce qu'elle a dit
c'est parce que je dis j'ai dit on me
dit 95% des gens qui meurent selon les
ehpad mais dans la vraie vie dans la vie
c'est la vie 95% tendance dépasse 95% en
plus de 65 ans mais simplement dans les
ehpad il faut aussi voir que vous avez
des gens ont une certaine promiscuité
qui fait que quand vous avez un cluster
un foyer fatalement que vous allez avoir
beaucoup plus de gens qui vont être
contaminés ou lu ce que quelqu'un de 85
ans vivrait tout seul chez lui donc
voilà la priorité des priorités pour les
personnes et puis priorité aussi pour le
système sanitaire parce qu'il est lu ta
ble ment une personne qui est vacciné
évitera l'hospitalisation la réanimation
d'accord je voulais aller pour les
pousser à se récrie nesle et importante
donné que que ça qu'elles sont d'un
cours en voyant les autres se faire
vacciner mon servat qui n'est pas moi ce
que je peux prendre mais ce que je
voulais dire très rapidement c'est que
oui parce que je me rends donc tout le
monde s'exprime bien sûr une cible a été
choisi c'était les ehpad
nous les médecins les gens que nous
voyons en hospitalisation la pitié
salpêtrière où dans d'autres hôpitaux et
en réanimation
c'est pas toujours des personnes des
ehpad donc j'ai beaucoup de personnes
ignorent effectivement 70 75 ans ne sont
pas obligatoirement dans les ehpad donc
que moi j'étais bien entendu d'accord
sur cette première cible des ehpad
mais je pense qu'il fallait l'élargir
effectivement au niveau de la caisse qui
a été alors c'est ce qu'on fait mais
heureusement parce que là aussi ça a été
si vous voulez un peu de polémique qui a
un peu modifié un petit peu la stratégie